this is a production of cornell
university
okay
thanks carol
sometimes they try to follow the rule
not bigger than it really is i think she
just did but uh yeah we're always
looking at innovative ways to try and
improve crop production and soil health
and
in my earlier years
soil health was not a big concern that
covered crops
that was nothing you really paid
attention to but
as time went on looking at what i
thought was
the demise or lusting of crop production
in the area that's when i started
focusing on cover crops and soil health
and
reduce tillage was a key part of it but
everything we've done seems to have
positive impact on our bottom line our
yields every year seem to be getting
better
inputs
seem to be going down somewhat if you
want to say nutrient management is
important part of it
focusing on banning all the nutrients we
can
our chemical dependency yes we're still
dependent on chemicals but
with our reduced tillage methods and
cover crops we finally been able to
reduce some of the herbicide application
rates instead of being on a maximum end
of scales be to the medium or lower in
the scales but
i think i've said enough
right now i'm going to introduce wally's
if i butcher anybody's names i apologize
but he's not even here okay
yeah but they're they're taping this and
recording it but
wally zakowski and mike zigna
mike's a field manager they started
using zone tillage about three years ago
they farm about 180 acres including vine
crops tobaccos cabbage and broccoli
they use zone tillage on pumpkins and
winter squash
they've been very pleased with the
results thus far especially the
spaghetti squash
planted on a heavy rye residue
they've shared their equipment with
three neighbors and have also heard
positive results well it doesn't look
like yields are different
which i wouldn't expect but they didn't
experience a yield drag apparently
there's much less wind erosion and
better drought tolerance in fields that
were zoned till
with this i'll turn it over to mike
he's going to explain the operation
thank you
how's everybody doing today
um my name is mike i
was at uh from plainville farm and
hadley madison down in the connecticut
river valley
um
we have uh
an extreme problem with soil compaction
down there
the reason we got it to zone till was we
grow our main one of our main crops is
butternut squash
and uh we had one year
where we ended up not being able to sell
a lot of it we also peel it but we were
not able to sell a lot of it due to a
lot of ground stain
so we started looking around
and
the zone tillage actually seemed like it
would be a pretty good idea to get into
for us for that reason
so the first year we ended up uh we
ended up finding a used machine
due to the price of a new one
um we made it suit our needs
um
most of our compaction was uh probably
from 15 to 19 inches down so we set the
machine for about 22 inches
so we wouldn't have a problem with
anything
and um
it seemed to do all right the first year
we tried it on a few acres about five
acres of fun or
and a couple acres of spaghetti squash
the real
the real
uh
difference we saw was more in the
spaghetti squash actually than in the
butternut
the spaghetti squash
seemed to not have anywhere near the
ground scarring
and was a lot cleaner
than than we had expected
the
the
cover crops weren't that great the first
year though
due to not previously planning on buying
a machine we had to work with what we
had from
from
the year before
which was the cover crops weren't as
thick as they should have been
but it was a good good trial experience
anyway
the second year that we used it
we increased our acreage a little bit
we went to uh
we went to about
four acres of spaghetti
i think it was about 10 acres of
butternut and
we also tried a few acres of sugar
pumpkins
the butternut once again
we didn't really see any yield
differences
but time wise spending instead of
spending a day and a half
longer to prep the field before we could
plant it
it you know if i started about 15
minutes before
wall-e was doing most of the planting
i could stay well ahead of them with the
machine which you know it's just better
ground moisture
less time less fuel
less aggravation
which that time of year is a good thing
to have less of
for the uh for side dressing we we
didn't have a uh
a machine
set up for side dressing so we ended up
taking one of our real estate elevators
with two
and we took all the rollers off of it
bought an old potato fertilizer hopper
with us with the transmission
mounted it on top of it and we had two
double disc openers that we put on the
side of it and we um
it worked out really well we
removed the disc openers about two
inches to each side of the plants
and we were about we were only a couple
inches in the ground
and it worked out really well it was
enough to cover this cover the dry
fertilizer
and not disturb
disturb the uh the soil too much so that
the um
the cover the cover crop was still there
before it was supposed to be
um
once again the quality the quality
was a big factor with this
the um
the third the third year
was uh
uh
that was 2009 that was that was an
extremely wet year
and uh this machine really it really
showed what it could do in that year
we had fields that uh
were next planted with butternut that
were next to another field of butternut
and our field had hardly any water
standing in it compared to the one that
was next to it same dip same
same knolls a lot of rolling ground
and
the disease pressure seemed to be a
little bit less
not a lot but
a lot enough enough to make a difference
where we actually sprayed one time less
than the fillet next to us
and the other big factor was when we
went through and sprayed the fields
we weren't sinking in up to a foot
foot and a half of the sprayer like the
other fella went through the fields for
which which makes a difference in the
end too
um
it uh the product
that year was
it was
it was our rate i mean nobody nobody had
a real good year that year where we were
and
the quality we store we store a lot of
the butter
the quality seemed
it seemed to hold up pretty good
it
it wasn't the best but like i said it
was it was a tough year
every year
the only thing i can say is every year
that we've been using the machine we're
finding um the more that we use it the
more we like it the more things we're
trying it on the more luck we're having
with it
and to be honest julia we really haven't
found anything we don't like about using
it
it's it's an easy machine to use it's
it's adjustable the wide variety of
crops
the one thing
that
that we noticed last year
this past season with it being as dry as
it was was wind eroding out where we are
there's a lot of guys that grow sweet
corn
and a lot of conventional tillage
and
when we were we were planting our squash
on the sweet corn feels very tilled and
there was a couple days there where
there looked like a sandstorm out there
you couldn't even you couldn't even see
the plant
but when you drove by the zone till
field there was hardly any sand blowing
there's a lot to be said for that the
plants the plants didn't get wind
whipped
uh not not from our field they dig in a
little wind whip from the other guys on
the other sides of us of course but
it was
it was interesting to see how we're you
know the way it worked that year as well
um
we did notice a difference too in the in
the uh
in the butternut that was on zone till
versus a conventional that um the plants
were healthier they seemed to for
whatever reason need to get down to the
water more or
i don't know what their reasoning behind
it was but it seemed to work out
very well for us
the fruit quality was excellent
the yields the yields were
where they should have been
they were up a little bit on our land
that we had the zone till on versus the
conventional fields only because the
plants seem to survive a lot better
the one thing that uh
that we're going to try this upcoming
year
using the zone till
the one thing
that i can't stress enough is
is that
as as much as you use is until the roll
cleaners
on the front of your plant are just as
important as the zone tilt is
if you're going through heavy rye
we actually on the spaghetti squash we
have
because it's planted a little bit later
the rye is usually taller and then it
mattes down and the zone till
two discs in the basket will actually
ride
over that matted ride to a certain
extent
and what happens is when the planter
goes through the first couple of years
we didn't have
the um
the rope cleaners on there
and
we ended up having to stock it over
and we went to a couple of meetings
sessions during the winter and after
that
we ended up it was brought to our
intention that the royal cleaners are
important and we ended up putting them
on
and since we've done that we haven't had
we haven't had this stock over or
or
you know restock a field that's been
it's been a
blessing
the thing the future coming down the
road what we hope to do uh this year
we're actually going to end up putting
road cleaners on on the zone till
machine
only because of
of the thickness of the ride
we don't really see
where it's going to affect anything else
um
every little bit helps
and
for we're shooting like uh
one of the machines at honor show
had a fertilizer hopper on it and we're
going to start uh
uh playing with banding bending some dry
fertilizers
only because every year the price of
fertilizer keeps going through the roof
um especially uh you know guys that are
growing corn with the potash cottage
here i guess it's going to be phenomenal
and uh any any
any little bit of money we can save you
know down the road is
is
money in our pocket
so
and then what we hope to really do is do
a one-pass tillage with mounting a
couple of uh
vacuum units behind the road units so
that one passed down the field will
literally take care of everything
that's that's what we we're striving for
that's probably two three years down the
road a little bit every year but um
that's that's hopefully where we uh
where we aim to be in a couple years and
like i say the more we've used it the
more we love it and
i can't uh anybody that talks to me i
just i can't i can't say anything bad
about the machine and i just i try to
encourage everybody to try it so
thank you
thank you mike anybody got any questions
for him quick
yes uh did you roll the cover cup or you
mowed it uh we just spray it and
go right through it yeah
you spray it plenty ahead yes we
usually
we usually
the cover crop we usually spray um
uh beginning april
as we're
we're not organic so
as early as we can spray it we will
except for the spaghetti squash because
it's planted a little bit later so we
let it let the rind stuff get a little
bit bigger
we're starting to experiment also so
this year we have a lot of sedan grass
in
so it'll be interesting to see how that
machine will do once a day ingress
after being laid down
and yes
you're not incorporating any harvest
leftovers so do you see any increase in
overwintering insects
in the after the one thing we uh we
chisel plow all our land after after we
go through harvest harvested crops
um
what we're what we're
aiming to do is try and get away from
the arrow which is you know non-vertical
tillage any vertical tillages seems to
work better for us so what we've done in
the past is just sew the rye and
run over with with a disc chisel
and it seems to work beautiful the ride
it takes a little bit longer for the
ride to come up but it does come up
decent you know it's a good stand how
deep do you go no with the chisel plow
about 12 inches
any other questions
all right thank you
thank you mike a couple uh while he was
talking a couple things he mentioned
wind erosion
up our way uh
on these nice winter days sometimes you
can drive up down the roads and
you can tell where conventional tillage
is done and we're reduced tillage is
done
just by the color of the snow banks on
the horizon
uh fertility he's talking about bending
depending more nutrients upcoming year
there's been you know test results
proven results that banning nutrients
get you a much higher efficiency rate so
so thus banding nutrients with a higher
efficiency rate you can use lesser
ratings
there's one pass
pass operation uh trying to put planted
units on the back
we do have some growers
where i'm from i'm 100 miles west of
here
20 miles outside of rochester new york
and there are some growers off our way
growing
corn
silage corn grain corn that
do have planters attached right behind
their zone builders and are doing a
one-pass operation
my concern is we have a lot of rock that
way and i'm afraid that planter pace
pays a pretty good toll sometimes uh
zone builder has a tendency to pull some
of those particles up but
they seem to be making it work all right
and it's a pretty efficient form one
pass
one person one tractor one passing the
crops in the ground
now we have joseph brightly he's gonna
give us his overview of what he's been
doing joel lives in hamlin
grew up working on his father's farm
dean p brightly farms growing processing
vegetables
cabbage and winter squash he graduated
from cornell in 2009
and enthusiastically tried his own
tillage in 2010
his father been kind of stepping on his
head a little bit holding him down a
little joe's pretty
pretty he is enthusiastic
joe's called me you know we've conversed
a few times at meetings on the phone
he's
got a real big interest in this reduced
tillage and trying to improve the crop
crop production
so far he's done a pretty good job so
joe turn it over to you
yeah as don said my day gives me enough
rope to hang myself
and then as i get close to dying he
pulls me back up so
i'm joe brightly from hamlet new york um
we're about
25 miles west of rochester five miles
north of broad port
we strip to about 1500 acres of mixed
grains
and vegetables
we use a case ih 1240 planter for just
about all of it
we have a 12 year old brilliant zone
commander and we have rtk gps
the gps is essential in my mind it helps
the operator see
where he's going even if we can't see it
allows him look back at the planter
there's a lot more going on whether it
be moving debris as you said rocks
and things like that
and at the end of the day it really does
help the operator from looking back like
this all the time and trying to focus on
where you're going makes your life a lot
easier
on our planter we have floating roll
cleaners which do whip away the debris
notice i say look away the degree you
don't want to be making trenches you
want to be just lightly moving the
debris away this allows the gauge wheels
to move
smoothly across the ground
which helps uniform seat depth uniform
seat depth is essential
you want to have them come up within
hours upon each other which will drive
you
we have pneumatic down pressure
which helps dramatically in different
field conditions zone till it actually
seeps a little more mellower than if you
go across the ground with a field
calibrator and a color packer if you go
from one section to fill the other on a
large field you'll be able to adjust the
down pressure now the best way i've
found to adjust down pressure is you get
the planter down
go back there you grab the gauge wheel
if you can't turn it at all you got to
lessen the ground the down pressure if
you can spin it freely
you need to increase it you should be
able to just turn it just a little bit
that's where you want to be
we have a fertilizer culture on front to
band fertilizer
we have a single disc
and you want if you have a lot of debris
look at non-fluid
coulters
sometimes the quilted the colder
discs will hair pin more
if you really have a problem with that
look at straight coulters
and in the back of this coat we have an
injector we have used the the knife and
the shank that goes right behind the
coulter we press it right up against it
even though it's compressed right up
against it we've still had issues with
corn stalks and other debris getting
wedged up in there creating
the cold air to stop turning and that's
a real pain
especially at 7 30 at night
these are the road cleaners they are
floating see these donuts right here
these are essential for these shark
teeth floating roll cleaners if not they
will do a lot of damage by moving debris
sometimes too much
these donuts help
put a uniform depth you can actually
also get wider donuts to help if you
have a really sandy ground
this is the medic down pressure this is
the airbag in there it's kind of tough
to see
and
there's a gauge up front with an air
compressor that you can adjust you can
actually do it from the cab on some
models so if you're going across the
field you can just adjust it increase it
or lessen it there
precision plane does have air force
which will actually increase
the planer so it's not pushing down as
hard if you have 100 pounds of seat in
the back you'll actually press it up
so it's not bulldozing as much and
create in lessening sidewall compaction
this is the fertilizer saddle
as you can see this is the injector
right here it's mounted a spring so it
moves around like a finger
and this is a very lightly
fluted coulter
i have not moved to straight cultures
yeah i've not had that big of an issue
i've just heard of that
okay our strip tiller is a 12 roll
brilliant can be folded up and the six
rows can be run as a deep ripper if you
want to run deep i actually told the
fella to go out there and take away all
the stops and he called me back and said
joe this
this disc won't pull it
i said wait it's only six rows it's a
425 horsepower tractor he goes it won't
pull it
i go out there and it thinks 34 inches
deep in the ground like well that's
probably why it's not fun
we run about 12 to 14 inches deep about
two inches above the plow pan and we'll
do this for about two or three years and
then we are going to shallow it up i see
no need and going down 12 14 inches if
you get rid of compaction
you can go we'll go six to eight inches
where we feel that we need to put down
our fertilizer because we are banding
fertilizer deep
we use a straight shank a lot of
parabolic shank in the bottom we're just
creating a slop to the ground to break
the compaction when it's wet
as it gets dryer you can use a probe
chain to kind of shatter it the power
pan similar to concrete
we use two front coulters that do help
size the material this can be an issue
if you have a lot of corn stalks 200
bushel corn heavy rod residue it will
plug up and shank or goes into the two
hilling holders
you need to have two front coulters the
size of this you might need to run them
pretty aggressively especially if they
will not break up how far apart
about four or five inches
and they're pretty fluted i think
they're an eight-wave hole there so
they're pretty aggressive
and fertilizer we're about eight inches
deep
we have tried dual placement with some
pnk deep i can't tell you results on
that
one thing i will say about fertilizer
going eight inches deep we did some
sweet corn
first of may we got a lot of rain and
the corn was about a foot and a half
tall and it was cold
i drive by the field and almost won the
ditch
it was green and yellow
i go out in there i cannot figure out
why
i actually called donny we talked about
it and he said
the thing you gotta realize is that
these roots
are about six inches deep right now
maybe eight inches and it's so wet
you're not going deep into getting that
fertilizer so my suggestion for all of
you if you're gonna band fertilizer when
it's early or if you have light ground
to put it six inches deep
that way the root will get to it we're
also banding fertilizer onto the planter
which is essential and i'm going to tell
you we're not side dressing any of these
crops anymore and you do not want them
to stress at any time because that will
reduce your yield
this is the double cultures on the front
you see they're pretty aggressive about
four to five inches apart
this is the shank and the closing discs
notice that the straight point in the
bottom
trust me it pulls hard enough without
the parabolic shank on it
this is our fertilizer delivery system
we have a two port or this is actually a
single port john blue piston pump right
off of the trimble
true guide system
goes from here in the red ball system
and it goes into these adjustable uh
fertilizer tubes here
now in the squash
uh what we did is we went in
two three weeks in advance on a failo
soybean field from previous year we
spread it down by phosphate let it burn
down and we actually did at the disc in
some areas of the rods
this is what it looked like directly
after planting
notice how there are clumps of dirt and
debris
looked away
and the seat belt looks very nice and
metal and flat if anything you want it
to be up a little bit yeah there are
times when i have had to run my fur or
my
rope landers deeper if it's very clumpy
what are you going to do you got to put
it deeper and create a trench you get
good seed to soil contact or you're
going to leave it up high you get poor
seed soil contact you're going to put it
down deeper
this is the squash after immersions
notice besides the doubles here
how uniform about
the
convergence is
that's what you want to see you don't
want to see some just coming up and some
this high you want to get them all even
as you can and there's actually no
cresting on here we got rain after this
and no crosstalk
for weed management it's very similar to
conventional only difference is that we
had to burn down first
we used command post plant
and we also used sandia where needed and
the areas that we did cultivate had
dramatically more weeds
and i mean to the row
in areas that we do not cultivate or
excuse me areas not disc we really do
not need a cultivating sometimes the
sandy did a very nice job
taking out the pigweed nut grass and we
didn't have any other um weed issues
but we did call it because daddy said
we're gonna
this is in the middle of july you can
see it's got a nice uniform canopy cover
you really can't ask for much more on
that in a squash field
for our yields you can see our strip
tilts on the left and crunches on the
right
notice there are fewer squash over here
there's more special here but more green
squash and carol just gave me this piece
of paper and i believe it says
in a 10 by 20 area there was fewer
squash over here on the strip till
more over here but these way more per
squash than these ones creating a total
yield
advantage for these wouldn't mean they
weighed more
i've just got a quick slide and snapping
don't have any nice pictures or anything
but we did do snap beans we did a piece
right after squash previous year came
out fine uh we were very pleased with
how they came up we do not deep band any
fertilizer
one thing i'll say that we learned the
hard way is you need to roll the snap
beans
especially on a lighter ground if not
you'll get
the ridges and maybe some small stones
and the guys that picked that do not
like that
after the good luck of that we did
double crop after peas and wheat when we
double cropped after peas if we planted
north and south with the peas we planted
east and west
that'll eliminate the wind rose of the
peas the pea orbisters they wind roll it
and if you go along with a row you had a
really tough time i don't care what you
have going through that so went the
other way
and we had
pretty good luck
very good luck um we actually one of the
thing there was a 40 acre piece and we
were gonna get three and a half inches
of rain or something like that i also
plant half the field
three days later three or four days that
we were planning the rest of the field
and nobody else was doing there was
nobody wrong we had to plant more
because we can get in there
following wheat strip towing
and it was amazing i think that's what
my dad finally said
i'm glad you went to college
and weed management is comparable to
conventional it's definitely not better
but you can handle you can deal with it
it's not the best it's not the worst and
i know that it beats work on the ground
four times
planning i can tell you that
now my summary is the management style
of reduced tillage is drastically
different than conventional you spend
less time burning diesel in your
character c more time in your office
you got to worry about the rotations
herbicide carryovers
and the fertilizer recommendations
remember you're not tilling the ground
you're not chisel plowing
line then or moldboard plowing lining
you got to go out there you got to
spread your potash in the winter let it
work down through natural gravity and
rain
you will get some movement from the
shank and the closing discs but remember
there's 15 to 20 inches that's not
getting tilted
so your ph will rise in that top inch
and you need to address that when you're
soil sampling that's something you got
to think of where am i going to soil
sample might get so simple every time in
the furrow or like a sporadically sample
that's something that is up for debate
who really does and you'll have to
figure it out i don't know i don't know
if any of you guys know i'd love to know
a
lot
what
that leads to another thing start at
your own pace we do not just do 1500
acres at once
year before we did try some on sweet
corn
and that your own pace maybe five acres
and maybe 20 acres
whatever you want to do don't be pushed
into it but don't be scared about it
talk to others and listen talk to him he
knows a lot he's actually very very open
conversation as i found out
most importantly stay positive we're all
going to have issues
trust me there were many times i
wondered what i was doing if i should
move away find it kicked out
stay positive it does work out in the
end
that's all i have to say
i think that's all
that's it
anybody got any questions for or
say a question what do you do after
harvest
tillage
question was what does he do after
harvest from tillage we will try to
no-till on the cover crop
or we will spread it right not by itself
or we will spread it and lightly
disconnect it all right have you seen
any increase in diseases or insects
because of that well it's our first year
so after harvest he spreads the cover
crop and either lets it lets it
germinate on its own like sometimes it
will or lightly incorporates it with a
disc
the
couple things that joe talked about the
nitrogen deep
uh crop crop blade getting to it
sometimes
we did we did see that
early on concerned me
the yield results in the end on the
sweet corn when we were doing a deplete
nitrogen and um
it concerned me because i could see
yellow corn
the corn was yellower where the nitrogen
was deep but when we got all said and
done and harvested the yield was
average almost two times the acre more
on those deep place nitrogen plots but
the
concern concern i've been
aware of and awakened to i guess as of
lately is
the soil as we improve the soil
biological health with reduced tillage
and cover crops
the
soil biological activity microbes
on the surface is where they
are the most active on the top few
inches
that
they let they need nitrogen
to survive
so they're
consuming the nitrogen on the shallow
part of your soil early on until things
really get going so there is a
possibility under certain crops and
certain fertility programs that you
could
be starving the crop of nitrogen
somewhat if you do not apply some
nitrogen
in the in the seed grow area or close to
the seed but
we're working on that
joe don't talk about weeds weeds and
cultivating and that that a few years
ago we had a we know till our peas and
uh came time to harvest one piece of
peas an 80 acre block of peas
uh got a heavy rain
well when it's time to harvest peas they
don't care if it rained or not it's time
to go and they go i got a call about two
o'clock in the morning and uh
needed me to bring my four-wheel drive
tractor down because one of the few
machines was stuck
that really excited you know not the
fact that they called me two o'clock in
the morning excited me but the fact that
one of those
i don't know 30 ton machines or whatever
was stuck out in my field
yeah they made a pretty good mess of the
field like i say an 80 acre block and
out of that we ended up
doing some remedial tillage on it after
the fact when it dried out something
with it with a desk trying to level the
ruts out
that fall we follow with winter we
follow peas with winter wheat don't tell
the wheat
we have to go to obviously go out and do
a burn down before we plant to control
the weeds but
where we anywhere we ran the disc over
the ground to level the ground out we
got the ground leveled out look pretty
good but
that that field or that farm has a very
high seat population of lamb's quarters
and about the only place the lamb's
quarters grew
was everywhere we ran the disc it was
like the thickest carpet of lamb's
quarters and it was right to the line
where we ran the disc on all those spots
we went out
spot disc if you want to see all the
ruts but
it's interesting what what tillage
awakens those seeds up if you want to
say and brings them to life but
rain rain and field operations
it's amazing
that not working this soil tearing it up
that
you get a rainfall on an inch of rain
can disappear pretty fast on that ground
where field next to you that they've
been tilled up
you don't even want to get close to it
there's been several times that the
processor
has got a hold of us after a rain to
either plant some sweet corn because
nobody else can go
matter of fact this past spring year ago
i was out planting sweet corn one monday
morning and they called me up and said
you know you got 50 acres of sweet corn
you're supposed to plant when do you
think you can go
he about dropped in his seat when i told
him i'm out going now what's the matter
oh it rained and nobody else can go
or harvesting they've called called me
up different times and said uh you know
we've had a lot of rain they're having
trouble everywhere else what do you
think about your blocking trade come on
i said it shouldn't be a problem they go
out and you know no problems
tire tire tread little tire tracks lug
marks but other than that goes good but
joe did
alert to the
fact that you might not spend as much
time in that tractor seat as you had
before you might not burn as much fuel
where you're going to spend more time is
sitting in the chair in the office
management
that's probably one of the one of the
biggest things or biggest
what i want to say time time
vacuums if you want to say is
much more management goes into this
conventional tillage
you go out you plow it you fit it you
plant it you know what you're going to
do with this here you're always looking
at new ways to improve the bottom line
increase your efficiency but
i can't stress enough that management is
much much bigger
part of the puzzle than
is first is first led to be thought of
i said enough on this
now we're gonna have casey coons
give us an overview of their operation
casey's the operation manager at
hamptondale farms
diversified farm with approximately 3
000 acres of cabbage green beans sweet
corn vine crops field corn alfalfa and
wheat they also operate a 700 cow dairy
and i do read the country folks even
though i'm not a dairy producer bruce
melt but i always look at the production
go through and eat every month when they
put the production report in there how
farms are going and i go through the
counties and that people that i
recognize and
they have a very respectable production
record and they also have some robotic
melters there too so
casey's responsibilities include
coordinating day-to-day cropping
enterprises overseeing equipment
operations maintenance repair
replacement
reduced tillage is a new effort on the
farm they've been working at it for a
few years now and casey and i have had
quite a few conversations over the years
and dale hill myself but
casey
it's your turn
thanks
thanks john i want to start out by uh
thanking you for the time and effort
that you've put in and your willingness
to share i know a lot of people have
called and
and it's really helpful getting someone
else's experience has been in a long
time so we really appreciate that thank
you
uh first
slide kind of speaks about our
philosophy and how important uh soil
health is is to our farm and the crops
and the animals that we have there
as dad mentioned we've been at it a few
years we've gradually worked into this
reduced tillage
we've kind of started by
ripping in the fall again to rip up some
of this compaction created from
vegetable harvest because as you
mentioned when it's time to harvest the
vegetables you have to go no matter what
the weather is and that can really
destroy soil
so we started out that way with um
with deep ripping in the fall and then
would go to just uh field cultivating in
uh in the spring
and um destroying the cover crop or or
burning it down
and then gradually work through that
and um
there's some points i want to want to
make a lot of it i think has been
reiterated here and i think it's on kind
of common themes from listening to the
rest of us
mobile plowing we feel really addicts of
soil to excessive tillage it kind of
perpetuates more tillage
being needed
when you do start going to reduce
tillage
you got to commit fort for two to three
years
it takes a while to start this soil
renewing process before you'll see the
results so as joe says you got you got
to stick with it
requires more management
that's the same thing don mentioned
before it does take more managing cover
crop the size of the cover crop when
you're going to burn it down make it
easier to work especially
with with a transplanter that doesn't
lend itself quite as well to
road cleaners and that sort of thing so
managing that size of the residue that
you're working with
is is more important
also if you want to be planning over the
slot that requires a gps which takes a
little more time to get used to
especially your first year there's
there's a learning curve there
but the soil will improve you'll see it
we've seen this action on the soil we've
seen more earthworm activity
you can see that happening and i've got
pictures that will show
the results that we see when we're
harvesting too
we used to do a lot of plowing a lot of
people used to do a lot of plugging
that's how you took care of the cover
crop
back then but unless the conditions were
just
perfect and
the moisture just right
it took a lot to get that to fit back
down again so that you could plant well
we are still
doing once in a while we'll plow bean
field a new mention she hasn't she
actually maybe seen a yield drag in
beans or all the other crops the yield
has stayed consistent and that's what
we've seen with the rest of the crops
with beans
we
sometimes are still getting our best
yield with plowing we plowed one field
last year
same reason it was a heavy sod there was
a running field a new field to us didn't
think uh the strip tiller would work
well in there
we did have some good beans off of that
but this being our first year of
following over the zone with our planter
our beans on the rest of our ground
reduced tillage has been much better
than it has been previously or we just
were
going with the field cultivator
this shows our
following with our field cultivator
after we've made a pass with the zone
building when we're doing cabbage we
still feel we need the truffle and
for weed control so we're still
incorporating treflan after we'll make a
pass for the zone builder to uh to put
down the nutrients
this shows a pass of zone building going
on
uh in the spring we are set up to put
liquid down
we're putting down uh a different amount
depending on what the crop history is
what our soil tests are and what our
yield
expectations are
as we mentioned before it does uh it
does take some more management
imagining managing the residue
and
working with the gps but it's real
critical to keeping that
over the zone this here is actually a
picture of what we do in the fall i've
heard some questions of what people are
doing in the fall
in the fall we'll go through and that's
a little bit
we're still finding 12 to 14 inches deep
in the fall to get below
to break up a compacted layer
this is our same
machine that we do the
zone building with in the spring
in the spring it's a 12 row unit
running more like
eight to ten inches deep
putting down the liquid we'll have the
rolling baskets and the discs behind it
in the fall we take off the two outside
shanks it's a little harder to pull it
at 14 inches deep we're taking off
rolling baskets into this and then we're
pulling an airway
sometimes that helps incorporate the
manure that we might put on in some of
the fields and also a cover crop that
we'll put in it'll help incorporate that
as well
and that shows uh what an established
cover crop will look like
we like to try to
destroy the cover crop when it's six
six to nine inches tall is what seems to
work well especially especially uh for
cabbage
part of the part of the
overall soil management once we get
going with
zone tillage and resource tillage is
then trying to manage the compaction as
we go through our operations
and harvest especially
one of the ways that we do that to help
minimize it is is with tract vehicles
and
with flotation tires
don was mentioning
it's in the harvest time especially when
it's wet when you can really visually
see
the difference between conventionally
tilled fields and in zone-tilled fields
and we have seen for years we used to
custom harvest beans and stuff
and it's a world of difference between
conventional till and and zone till
this year it was a conventional
tilt field of cabbage near us
this was us operating the same day
there is a little track there where we
where we had a tram line where we'd be
bringing back from the other end we
would follow the same path back out but
you can see all there is is just a
little bit of the real
wheel treads uh shown from the harvest
and very little uh running going on we
get much better water infiltration in
the soil structure improves and that's
that's one way you can measure and see
the difference
so our goal is to get away from
something like that
in the fall
and to end up
something like that
the soil will improve it takes some time
to see it when you're first
transitioning
but it's really uh well worth it uh
at
the end
so with that
take any questions if anybody has
anything
okay thanks thanks
a couple couple points casey was talking
about the you know the water
infiltration part of it and that
you know we've seen that in our
operation and i guess
what really hit the home run with me
when
i have
landlords
that make the comment to me that
i don't know what you're doing but it
must be right because we don't have
water that ponds on our land anymore
like the neighbors do across the road
that are conventionally tilled
or you know when they're paying
attention and watching what you're doing
and
make positive remarks like that or
my garden doesn't get flooded anymore
when it rains because the water used to
run out of the field prior years come
down the edge of the road and fill my
yard in the garden
snow geese don't have a pond to land on
anymore in my field because
we don't have a pond i feel bad about
that they went somewhere else but
some of these reduced till
tools
turbo desk turbo till
nrcs if you're
in one of their
programs they
some of these they don't view real
friendly the
case ih turbo disk i know there are some
areas that
they call it a full width tillage tool i
guess even though
this last fall we had our new district
district manager for our county
i was applying for the
conservation stewardship program
and we put some cover crop we put cover
crops after our sweet corn we do have a
turbo disk
i
tell people i might have to rename that
just to a turbo and forget the desk
but
they have to come out and do it do a
field field and farm survey to check
things and i took them around some of
these fields where we put the cover crop
on after the sweet corn we air flow it
on mix it with potatoes generally put
potash sometimes a little ammonium
sulfate but we'll air flow the cover
crop in some fertilizer on we get even
distribution that way
and then we run over the ground with the
with the
turbo
approximately two inches deep
we've done this for two years now and
cover crop establishment with this tool
is just phenomenal
and when he came out for the farm farm
survey i took him around with some of
course i had to show him all the fields
and took him to the fields where he put
the cover crop on and ran and ran over
it with the turbo and he was very
impressed with the amount of residue
that was left on top you know we had
good coverage and all that but
the powers to be above them are the ones
that really make the decision now so
i know in uh lesser publications
the no-till farm magazine there was an
article about it that some of these
minimum till tools and nrcs's view on
them is not very favorable that
maybe more of us need to start making
noise about it and
there's yeah there's places places out
there that i could see you know very
rolling ground hilly ground
you know where maybe that maybe this
tool would not be advisable to use but
there's a lot of other places where they
can be very beneficial but
with that
i'm turning over ron wagner from wagner
farms in rome new york
ron has 35 acres of mixed vegetables and
they're known for their potatoes farm
stand
farmers markets greenhouse plant sales
in the spring you pick currents
raspberries and gooseberries homemade
wreaths and christmas trees
so around
and turn the table over to you
thank you thank you
i started department about
1998 officially i was farming for about
five years before that involved with ffa
many of you probably were too
i have
fought the system 100 all the way
started out a couple acres here and
there
and a little monk farm a lot of small
tractors a couple
small pieces of equipment
gradually operate i moved up in the
world and got into a little larger scale
and
around 2006 we were running about 75
acres of crops
one running it all on one tractor
working 18-hour days
180 days a year at least
2006 was a bad year
as many of us know it was a very wet
year we had many floods
and
i
despite having crops when no one else
did i went bankrupt
and
thought that was the end of it
07 was bankrupt a year i didn't do
anything my mom took over the farm
ran the farm
we did all right
covered the bills covered the expenses
that year
in 2008 i started
with a clean slate i was able to keep
all my equipment keep everything
i started looking at ways of conserving
money and
making things more economical
and of course around 2008 fertilizer
prices started pushing almost a thousand
dollars a ton towards the end of this
growing season
conventional tillage
was my main tillage tool
go in
alright plow
and of course in 2008 i had downsized my
port i was down to 35 acres big load off
the tractor
the conventional tillage methods i was
using that was moldboard plowing
um
originally i started out with big heavy
set of discs
and of course like every said this you
have to go over two or three times and
make it look good
try to fit the ground
i
gradually transitioned over to to a
effecta ii
field cultivator which i love and to
this day i use almost
90 of the time
very rarely use a side discs in the
field any longer except for him to fall
off and try to chop down stubble
or
chew up residue
the
idea of going to a reduced tillage
system
back around 2005 i sort of messed around
with it
via a sub-soiler
and trying to eliminate some compassion
layers i did that on a tomato crop that
year
and
it was one of our best tomato crops ever
it went in some sold the whole entire
field laid the mulch did all everything
we could
it was a dry summer
the tomatoes did phenomenal they did not
drought stress we
irrigated once or twice that's all we
had to do
by going with the subsoil or going 28 i
went 28 inches deep with it i hit it
really hard really deep
i gave those roots of those plants the
opportunity to go deep on their own
to find the water source to find the
moisture to find the nutrients that have
leached down deep in the soil over the
years
at that point i became
convinced that
jointly reduced or
to
get down to get the root system down
deeper in this ground was a was a
priority
and this past year in 2010
i had the opportunity to use a
unifirth
130 zone builder
from
freeville
okay
a couple
nine thousand dollar piece of equipment
give them to me for free to trip demo
and try out
you know what
sounds good to me
what kind of heart
i tried it on sweet corn and cucumbers
first
the sweet corn
i did on my white sweet corn on
a late a second and third planting
and i did it i did it right next to the
second
we're first planting actually white
sweet corn on conventional tilled soil
so i had a side by side comparison
the white sweet corn that was on the
zone build
didn't lodge
didn't fall over
yielded just just as well as this
conventional
however the conventional lodged
real complaint about the thicket
definitely
um
i didn't do anything different than the
fertilizer we just broadcast
we use broadcast on our fertilizer
program we do some liquid infer when we
plant
and
this at the same time i did the first
planting was the second and third
planting of white sweet corn i did the
cucumbers
i did not have success with that um
i i lead that to the fact that we had
heavy rains just after we planted
and
this small seed of cucumber actually
wound up being washed down in the soil
down the
some soil riches
deeper than i should have
i also believe it also the soil crusted
just a little on top which hindered it
from germinating correctly
all right
later this summer this past summer i
decided
we could get this we could get this one
going again so we've decided we're gonna
do our whole entire fall crop of coke
crops broccoli cauliflower cabbage
chinese cabbage kohlrabi
you name it i put in a
i went a little excessive i
i didn't plan on the field
and what i was going to use it for
originally
and i didn't go in and spray it with
roundup i wish i had because i would
have saved a lot of energy in a lot of
time
instead i went up
the day i
went ahead and i
chiseled out the field i dissed it twice
i ran the perfecto over with a roller i
got it all nice uniform flat weed free
the following day i went over it with
the zone builder
i was all builder
two rows
and
i was running 14 inches deep in the
ground it was about two inches below my
compaction layer
i was running around five miles an hour
with a 55 horse tractor
overdrive fully loaded perforates
a lot of equipment on the back
didn't even first i sat on the ground i
didn't even know it was there just pull
so nice and easy in the ground
the field i went with for the cold crops
has a problem though
conventional plowing of it
is hard because the top end is a clay
long
you go down the middle of its clay
those two the depth control is pretty
decent you can control it you get the
ground get the plows on the ground even
in the dry weather
however the far end is a gravel knoll
and
because of the gravel
the hard pan and the gravel layer
falls right up by the ground and only
maybe you get in the ground two three
inches at the most
the zone builder however
we got down 14 inches we stayed at 14
inches right through that gravel knoll
cool you know what this might be good
this uh
this might actually transplant and
normally conventionally all the standard
transplanters
you want your soil to be plowed
pretty deep for the transplanter to
actually work the way it's supposed to
so on the gravel mold the transplanter
was usually well okay lift it up we're
not going to plant it here just turn
around go back
this year we wound up planting right
from one end of the field to the other
right through that gravel knoll
with no problems
day after i zone build that field
we had
approximately two to three inches of
rain that following day
and i was like well
zone builder got picked up and i bet you
i'm going to be
hurting here because i can't get back in
that field it's going to be all crusted
over
conventionally tilled field
would have been crested over completely
it would have been impossible to go in
with transplanter and transplant on top
of that
however
taking a risk we put the transplanter on
about five days after we zone billed it
we started transplanting the cold crop
about
three o'clock in the afternoon
by
nightfall
we were three quarters away done
planting
and we had no problems it went in the
ground it stayed in the ground
the zones were nice and fluffy
full width of the baskets which i think
we're running about 12 inches wide on
the baskets
the
zone itself was 14 inches took off and
took a
metal rod out with me a couple spots
pushed it down through nice right 14 15
inches deep
transplant work perfect
all right looking good
we went in and
irrigated the following day we saw
irrigation on the field
and
we ran about three quarters of an inch
of rain
on the field
and we did this for three days we could
move the sprinklers around it over the
three day period we got it all wired in
we did not have to irrigate again for an
hour two weeks after that and this was
when this was in the middle of a pretty
dry spell in the end of july that we had
normally i would have had to irrigate it
two or three times probably five days
apart i didn't have to worry about it
saved me a lot of headaches
the
benefit to the zone building was that
it did once that surface was sealed it
kept the moisture in that it allowed the
roots to go down deep and allowed them
to find the moisture
we also at the same time zone build it
we had broadcasted fertilizer so the
fertilizer was already in the ground was
ready to go
we did not use any liquid we didn't use
any water or liquid fertilizer at the
time of transplanting
which
was a risk at the time but it paid off
the
cold crop did phenomenal this year
about halfway through the growing season
in ju in august we had
one weekend where we got four inches of
rain in one day
normally that field can pool up you
would have 12 inches of water sitting in
the low spot
okay crop is lost right
we had no water standing in the field at
all
the
spot where normally the bees pulled up
yeah the tire tracks had a little bit of
water standing in that was it
the roads themselves were
quite muddy
but the tire tracks you could actually
walk on you could actually drive on them
if you had to
the harvest came in on about september
we started picking uh broccoli and
cabbage
the broccoli heads were hauling out up
field were 10 to 12 inch diameter
consistent yield
harvesting it every three days
the cabbage was averaging six to eight
pound size
we were wholesaling it we were retailing
it farmer's market you name it we were
doing it with him
everyone loved the quality
i loved the quality i didn't have to
worry about being selective about
picking it for once
i didn't have to worry about it because
in the past i've had broccoli lodge on
me
all over getting mud
this year i didn't do it
so i was fortunate there
this fall i decided we'd try it again
and
i did it on my garlic field actually
i zoned build the uh garlic rose
i believe by doing
zone builds
our area
16 inches seem to be to be the correct
number
harvestability of crops crop loss stuff
like that
since 1996 when we first started
experimenting with zone till
the only sweet corn
that ever ever got bypassed in the field
above and beyond excess
yields
was some conventional we had one year
that the quality wasn't good enough that
was when we were we were still
in the transition phase if you want to
say
and part of our acreage was conventional
and part of it was zone till because i
wasn't quite brave enough to go all the
way yet but
that one particular year we had some
conventional sweet corn that got
bypassed because the
quality and yield was not good enough
but yet all of our zone tilt corn got
harvested that year
so i think that was year i finally
decided that enough's enough i'm giving
up on a conventional
seed the soil or root the soil contact
is critical
but whatever you do to the ground you
need to have good contact you know
seatbelt preparation is important
now we're going to hear from jim wilson
from wilson farms
jim farms
600 acres in new hampshire with 32 acres
of lexington maine
maine is located
in michigan
from boston
12 miles from boston he grows pumpkins
squash sweet corn carrots and crops on
raised beds jim has a sub soiler
but those pesky rocks were a problem
he now has a straight shank under first
zone builder
he has a compaction problem and has
this one's thrown a little fight taft
for uh
cass camp sikka
okay
i wasn't good in english
french i never took it so
italian or latin or whatever i've
dreaded root crown and fruit disease
of skelos yeah you'll have to say it for
me because
selenasia
and curcumin crops
he has done three years of classic zone
intelligent hampshire
the system works well
for pumpkins squash
sweet corn
he uses zone till on raised beds
the farm has 75 crops
i guess he's diversified
two years ago he lost 80 percent of his
carrots
this year after planting them on zone
built beds
he had to buy bigger bags because the
carrots are too big
for this turn it over to jim thank you
jim
thanks
good
thank you um
the advantage to going last here is that
basically everything you wanted to say
has already been said
and
we farm about 600 acres in new hampshire
up there we we do this the classic
classic crops all of our largest space
consuming crops are all up there
and generally what what everybody else
has spoken about today is the type of
thing that we do
in lexington we've been farming for 127
years
we get three crops a season off of every
bit of it
and we grow a lot of quick turnover
smaller crops
and between the two crops
excuse me between two farms we do about
125 different crops basically raising
everything we can for our retail stores
at both locations
and
we did we've done this this will be our
fourth year in new hampshire it's worked
so well up there with what we've been
doing
that we decided
you know we've had some serious
compaction issues in lexington where
we're turning over the land three times
a three three crops per season is an
awful lot of tractor trips
now
um so we you know we kind of hadn't
heard of anybody doing this type of an
application
but
we're we're gamblers like every farmer
and we bought a second machine and we
we tossed our three uh
the three shanks together
we can put three rips on a five foot bed
and
it's it's improved drainage tremendously
you walk across the farm and you forget
that
you forget that after a wet period and
step on that plastic before it'll
disappear
it's we've also noticed huge
improvements in in irrigation issues
i think that some of the economic
analysis that people i've heard earlier
today you know you've talked about total
yields etc
we've found that the products
are coming off cleaner and better
pumpkins are cleaner in new hampshire
uh lettuce this year hot dry season we
do them all from transplants 128 plugs
we're throwing right into these zones
we do them by hand we transplant them
right behind these these
what we would do
in this application we haven't put
plastic as you see here
and what we would do is we would come
down once with the better prepare the
ground once with the better
write down with the zone till and then
better the opposite direction to smooth
off the bed and then seat as we always
would
um
it's uh we i did not have a single head
of lettuce bowl this summer
and in a hot dry year generally you
plant a 128 plug and you grind it up
after you've harvested and you see
basically the same plug with a few
little hair roots sticking out
this year i got down a couple of times
and dug out and as best i could with my
hands and you'd find root zones that
were beyond the canopy of the legs and i
think that had a whole lot to do with
the fact that you weren't didn't have
anything bolt
um this is just a long-term view of what
we were doing there this is going to be
this is all zucchini field and
this is going to be
you know we run down with the plastic
right behind the zone till we get to the
end of the field turn it around and come
back
biggest mistake we made this year uh as
i said as was said in the previous notes
a couple years ago i had a field i
didn't have i very limited as to where i
could plant on this 30 acres so i uh
i put my carrots in what i knew was a
pretty poor spot it was a heavy wet year
um
we lost probably 80 of our carrot crop
to fork it
and i sent it out for analysis i was
sure it was nematode and they came back
clean
it was nothing but soil compaction which
is really what prompted us to try to
figure a solution here
this year
the carrots came i've been using that
same bag to sell carrots in my market
for 25 years
this is the first year we could barely
seal the bag because because of the
length of the carrots
and i think when you talk in economic
analysis too
um
a carrot that's three inches longer is
going to be 20 percent heavier so the
tonnage you're taking out of a field
it just makes sense that that would be a
definite improvement
you know you can see a close-up of the
same type of thing it's uh it's just
it's phenomenal and none with that but
these carrots they will
that bag is 16 inches long
those are 14 inches long and they're not
horsing at all
very very good very tender
tomatoes i noticed this year with the
crop wheat we did it just as we did with
the zucchini they ripped right
underneath the plastic
when i went to first of all we had the
best crop of tomatoes i've ever seen
and
one of the things about it was you know
it was a good tomato here it's hot it
was dry
it was they were early
but the vigor on the plants was
tremendous and i noticed when we finally
finished the end of the season we got
beyond frost i had to go out and chop
them up it took me two more passes with
the rota bear to grind up the vines
because they were because the root
system was that much larger
now i've noticed little things in the
field you'd walk by a field of beets and
at noon time in the heat of the day you
see it's just slightly wilted normally
you just grab some irrigation pipes and
run at it
and well you got busy i was running drip
that day i came back at four o'clock and
they were standing straight up sun just
that little bit a little bit cooler a
little bit a little bit better condition
and so you don't have to panic quite as
much we're finding
again i think a huge huge part besides
the fuel and
and the
and the time savings as far as setting
fields up is all obviously
also that the fact that you do not have
to irrigate anywhere near as much of the
system the root systems
justify themselves and i think the
quality of plants is the biggest part
and
really that's about all i had to say
most of the most of the heavy hitter was
uh was taken by the guys in front of me
but
there are any questions
this is different yeah
it's a head it's a it's a heavy loan
this is any loan in lexington new
hampshire is a sandy one
san diego in new hampshire we're down on
the merrimack river
just
right on the river
those flatbeds are raised
those are going to be raised that those
happen to be
flatbeds for the zucchini but everything
else is grown on raised beds now we're
growing things like i didn't mention
baby spinach
you get a 24 day turnover from seed to
harvest and that has got to be 100 clean
any debris in the field you can't do it
so that's why we're forced to be
we've always been high tail i use no
herbicides at all on the farm in
lexington
i cultivate a tremendous amount i know
what the detriments are to that
but
we're bringing high value crops off and
we feel we can we can control it we've
kept the farm clean
it's extremely rare to see any any weeds
go to seed at all on the lexington farm
we patrol it every day
did you try one shank or did you just go
from three we went right to three um
we were trying to lay out i i
to save some money i was thinking well
maybe maybe two's the number and we
could pull it with a little bit less
horsepower
but uh
my guy who does most of my tractor work
for me he said no i'm gonna do it do it
all you know both feet in and
i'm glad we did
how many rows of carrots do you have on
that bed
three three rows on the bed three rows
three zones
40 inches at the top of the bed okay
three rips and three rows yep yeah
so when you're doing what's the sequence
of events when you're building a raised
bed
say that again well at the beginning of
the season we would plow as always
and we prepared the soil you would
flatten it out with a with a power arrow
and
then you come down once with the better
and then rip the bed
and there's it would be a little bit
uneven because of because because of the
ripping process and then one more pass
with the better and then see as normal
and then you put the plastic on at that
point oh well plastic or bare ground
anybody
and it hasn't been too soft for going in
with like baby spinach
on the top it's that second pass with
the better that's
just enough
and it does it doesn't settle no
surprisingly if you get a rain after
immediately after or generally
you know where
it's a small scale farm i mean we're
we're
and
you know we would normally seed and
honestly move the pipes in and overhead
irrigate within within a half an hour
plant trying to get germination up
and we don't see any you know nothing
nothing falls down
anybody
very good
thank you
thank you is there any questions for any
other speakers before
everybody bows out
they're here it's a good opportunity to
ask them questions if you have any
i guess um i'd like to know what um for
some of you you think you might try next
like
do you see changing anything or doing
anything new or different this next year
we did
we did 100 i mean we
we generally jump both feet when we jump
and um we did uh every bed on the farm
was done done this way last year now it
was a dry year
next you know you almost guarantee this
year will be a wet year so we'll go
we're going to find out what the
differences are and you make all those
small adjustments after
how about mike
uh
we're actually going to try a little bit
of cabbage and some broccoli this year
and uh
oh excuse me
we're going to try some cabbage and
broccoli this year and also uh we grow a
couple acres of beet so we're going to
start messing around with a few things
like that
uh only because like i say every
everything we've tried it on we've loved
it on so i don't see any reason not to
try it on everything eventually
this will be the first year that with
the gps that we'll be able to follow in
the spring the slot that we cut in the
fall
so we'll be putting on our liquid
fertilizer and doing our zone building
right over the same slot we cut in the
following
plant
i want to try a bio strip with the
radishes
and for all this time
i guess the big thing we're going to do
is i've got another planter coming we're
going to do twin rows we're going to try
twin rows and
follow over the zone behind his own zone
till our strip tiller
compare that to our 30 inch rows
they're going to be 7 7 or eight inches
apart
so
if we drive drive right they'll be
straddling the strip
gonna try to compare apples to apples as
best we can have the planter set up so
that the fertility program is the same
as our 30 inch grow planter and then
obviously try to
try pushing some populations above and
beyond that
on another
replicated strip somewhere but
i want i want to compare
what i'm doing now with a twin row and
see if there's an improvement and then
try any advancements from that but sweet
corn sweet corn soybeans grain corn
how far apart would the rows be between
the twin rows like
you have two and two are they going to
still be at 30. there's going to be well
they're going to be centered on 30 inch
rolls centered on 30. centered so
there's going to be approximately 22
inches between
between the rows so we'll still be able
to get down through with this with the
row crop sprayer
so
okay
always looking and trying
well i tried a year ago to
several equipment companies to see if we
could get one to do i mean i call this
an experiment you know i got a 50 000
experiment going on but
you know
god and things were good to me last year
so i was able to justify it but
i decided i was going to jump into it i
wasn't out waiting i'll try and check
the equipment companies again and see
cef or see what and
then i didn't want to go to a 12 really
deal i tried to sell my 12-row unit so
when i buy something i want to buy
something for the future not something
for yesterday
so we're looking at the newest
technology and
you know the equipment company
recommends this
what they recommend you know i kind of
go by recommendations or
or talking with other people that are
using it but
you know back to the transition phase
we're transitioning for the future not
for not for the history behind us so
sometimes there's not a lot of
opportunity to check with check with
people or to find out what works what
doesn't work or what to buy what not to
buy so sometimes you have to go out on a
limb
myself i hope it works i fall in love
with it
or
the bailout i hope somebody else likes
it better than i do
something fortunately for us you know
what we've done
it's all worked
if it doesn't work find out why it
didn't work
as was said here
joe and casey and ron and jim and that
that
you know
don't be afraid to talk to people that
are doing it that's your best best
source of information there's people out
there that are doing that you know i go
to these national dome tell conferences
and there's people actually there's
people from around the world
that come to these and
you know not everything works the same
everywhere but you'll find different
pockets around the country around the
world that
go through the same same situation the
same circumstances that you have
you know you go out in ohio now and you
talk about no-till callers or row
cleaners majority of the people out in
ohio
they certainly have god's dirt because
they're taking all these attachments off
they're just going out with a planter
and planting well
i know from past experience
we can't do that on airsoft here in new
york we have to add all those options on
there to get back to that seed to soil
contact
fertility management
there's a lot of a lot of growers out
west now you know the big talk is
starter fertilizer where
what do you need that for you know our
fertility is good enough but now tester
is also coming in you know comparisons
that the little starter fertilizer is
showing some some benefits particularly
phosphorus get phosphorus by that seed
you know get it going
i could i could go on for the rest of
the night if i wanted but
i was supposed to adjourn at 5 30 and
so if there's any other questions for
anybody here
please do um
do the um evaluation and remember if
you're interested in a demo there's some
sign up sheets on the back
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu